[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur france 24 et
sur radio france internationale pour une
interview exclusive avec abdoulaye diop
le ministre malien des affaires
étrangères il est avec nous depuis
bruxelles est avec moi pour cette
interview christophe boisbouvier de rfi
monsieur le ministre bonjour
bonjour remarque
monsieur le ministre suite à l'annoncé
par le danemark du retrait de ses
troupes spéciales du mali le ministre
français des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian a dénoncé je le cite des
mesures irresponsables prises par une
junte à nouveau je le site illégitime
votre réaction
ma réaction c'est d'abord c'est
surprenant de la part d'un diplomate de
la trempe de monsieur le drian qui parle
au nom d'un grand pays la france ce sont
des propos empreints de mai plus de
mépris ce sont des propos que je
condamne qui sont inacceptables et je
crois que les insultes ne sont pas une
preuve de grandeur il est bon que
monsieur le dia comprennent que ce ne
sont pas les insultes qui a réglé pour
le mans tours nation qu'elle ce que nous
attendons de la france grande nation
qu'elle puisse à avoir une attitude
constructive moins agressive moins
hostiles et moins empreinte de mépris
vis-à-vis des autorités maliennes qui
incarne aujourd'hui la souveraineté de
notre pays alors on va revenir en / / /
takku bas mais tout d'abord sur sur
paris vous parlez de mépris vous parler
d' insulte alors une question simple
enfin plusieurs questions simples est-ce
que vous allez exigé des excuses de
paris est-ce que vous songez par exemple
à prendre des mesures telles que le
rappel de votre ambassadeur en france où
convoqué l'ambassadeur de france à
bamako
le mali n'exclut rien de la table si la
souveraineté et le peuple malien ne sont
pas respectées nous ne demandons pas des
excuses à paris nous demandons que par
une respecte en tant que pays nous
respectons la france nous respectons le
peuple français daria pas de problème
entre le peuple français et le peuple
malien mais l'attitude des autorités
françaises doit changer pour prendre en
compte cet élément qui a des autorités
responsables au niveau du mali et que
seul un engagement avec ces autorités
permet de gérer leur présence au mali et
cette présence doit répondre
aux intérêts supérieurs du mali et nous
sommes en train de revoir plusieurs
accords et traités de défense pour nous
assurer que cet été ne viole pas nos
dispositions constitutionnelles ne viole
pas les délais la souveraineté du mali
et prendre en compte l'intérêt du mali
si ce n'est pas le cas le mali
n'hésitera pas soit à dénoncer soit a
demandé un réajustement de ses
différents traités nous sommes
conscients que certains dé ses
arrangements ont été conclus par le
gouvernement précédent il ya la
continuité de l'état derrien le seul à
être au dessus de l'intérêt supérieur de
maliens que le président guittèye le
gouvernement sont disposés désormais à
assumer et à s'assumer pleinement et
nous souhaitons que la france et
d'autres partenaires inscrivent aussi
leur action par rapport à cela et j'ai
salutaire la décision sage des autorités
danoises de retirer leurs forces simple
d'acrimonie et nous sommes disposés à
continuer le dialogue avec l'ensemble de
leurs partenaires pour la sécurisation
du mali et la stabilité de l'ensemble de
la région alors ce vendredi monsieur le
ministre c'était chez nos confrères de
rtl le ministre français jean yves le
drian est revenu à la charge si j'ose
dire en disant que désormais c'était la
rupture du cadre politique et du cadre
militaire nous ne pouvons pas rester en
l'état at il dit on va voir comment on
peut adapter notre dispositif en
fonction de la nouvelle situation
je crois que monsieur le drian gloire
comprendre que l'engagement avec le mali
ne doit pas se faire à travers les
médias et que si ce type de questions
sont en discussion nous sommes tous des
diplomates il ya deux canaux pour
pouvoir discuter de ces questions le
malien non plus n'exclut rien par
rapport à ces questions si ça ne prend
pas en compte nos intérêts donc les
menace les investir les insultes doivent
cesser pour donner la place à un
engagement réaliste un engagement
constructif entre responsables pour
pouvoir voir ensemble comment surmonter
cette difficulté commencé pour faire
face aux défis que nous avons qui sont
des défis sécuritaires
donc pour l'instant le vous ne vous
parlez pas entre entre vous deux
ministres des affaires étrangères du
mali et de la france le les ponts sont
coupés pour l'instant
les points le mali est et reste toujours
ouvert au dialogue
vieille nation de tolérance et de
dialogue augmenté dans cette posture la
dernière fois que j'ai rencontré
monsieur le drian c'était à new york on
a eu un entretien franc et direct elle
nous restons toujours ouvert je
m'entraîne régulièrement avec d'autres
autorités françaises
malheureusement monsieur le drian ou
d'autres responsables français on les
entend plus sur les médias parlant du
mali et que d'avoir vraiment un
engagement constructif au lieu de
soulever le monde entier aujourd'hui
contre le mali je le rappelle cette
attitude agressive ou hostiles à
l'endroit du mali n'a rien à voir avec
les raisons qui sont mises en avant à
liées au respect de la démocratie au
respect des droits de l'homme à des
coups d'état non
le mali est punie parce que les choix
politiques des autorités du mali ne
conviennent pas à certains je crois que
nous devons pouvoir sortir de ça parce
que même les coups d'état dont on parle
la france a applaudi des coups d'état
quand ça va dans le sens de ses intérêts
elle condamne quand ça va dans le sens
contraire de ses internautes cette
politique des deux poids deux mesures
aussi doit cesser vous pensez au tchad
je ne pense absolument à rien et il ya
eu beaucoup des pays où on a eu des
situations il ya eu de politique de deux
poids deux mesures est de la france et
même de nos organisations africaines
monsieur le ministre
concrètement vous avez demandé il ya peu
de temps la révision de l'accord de
défense avec paris est ce que vous avez
reçu une réponse et si cette réponse
n'est pas satisfaisante
est ce que vous êtes prêt donc comme
vous semblez l'indiqué a dénoncé cet
accord donne et de défense avec la
france
absolument nous sommes absolument très
clair que si nous avons demandé dans un
cadre du plô matic nous avons soumis un
protocole amender avec l'ensemble de nos
amendements que vous me permettrez de ne
pas le détail ici parce que les
dispositions de l'actuelle traités en
matière de défense certaines
dispositions sont contraires à la
constitution et la souveraineté du mali
nous avons décidé à les revoir nous
attendre une réponse rapide de paris à
défaut de réponse
assurez vous que le mali s'assumer rats
par rapport à cela
est-ce que donc le mali songe à demander
le départ des soldats français de son
sol cette question n'a pas pour le
moment sur la table mais le sera a
visiblement puisque vu la situation a vu
votre ton est l'heureux les rapports
avec paris qui se tendent c'est quand
même une possibilité que vous disiez
mais en effet ça marche pas depuis des
années les soldats français ne font pas
le job entre guillemets il faut qu'il
parte
ce qui est sûr c'est que pour le mali si
une présence à un moment donné est jugée
contraire aux intérêts du mali nous
n'hésiterons pas à nous assumer mais
nous n'en sommes pas là qu'est ce que
vous répondez jean yves le drian qui dit
qu'il faut rester digne regarder 53
soldats français tombés au mali
je demanderai à monsieur le drian de
rester digne aussi parce que avant nous
nous nous reconnaissons les sacrifices
des soldats français
l'intervention française qui a été
décidé au mali a été fait dans un bon
état d'esprit des de notre pays nous
apprécions cela nous apprécions tous les
concours qui ont été faits dans ce cadre
là mais aussi on doit comprendre que
avant que la france ne vole au secours
du mali le mali et les africains aussi
sont venus mourir
si en europe pour la libération et la
liberté de ces pays donc nous avons tous
des jets de sang les uns envers les
autres et si on de dépasser cela est de
bâtir des cadres qui nous permettent
vraiment de répondre aux solutions et
pas à travers des dictats de millas des
invectives je crois que ça se fera
seulement dans le cadre de nos intérêts
mutuels dans le cadre du respect dû à
chacun mais qu'on rêve on arrête cette
mobilisation toutes ces campagnes de
dénigrement contre les autorités
maliennes nous ne sont pas impressionnés
par cela monsieur le ministre vous nous
avez parlé de la russie parmi les
partenaires du mali or il ya quelques
jours le général américain stephen
townsend qui command africom a affirmé
le groupe wagner c'est à dire les
paramilitaires et mercenaires russes le
groupe wagner et au mali ils sont
plusieurs centaines
le monde entier le voit et cela nous
préoccupe est ce que vous confirmez
encore une fois je ne sais pas plus
impressionnée vous savez c'est la même
amérique notamment à travers les
collines power qui au conseil de
sécurité des nations unies a montré des
photos satellitaires ait des preuves au
monde entier qu'ils nous ont tous
convaincus que l'irak disposait d'armes
de destruction massive la suite de
l'histoire vous la connaissez elle était
totalement fausse donc ce sont des
mensonges a été mêlé à ce pays
absolument et pourtant le commandant
américain d'africom ajoute que wagner
bénéficie du soutien d'avions de l'armée
russe pour son déploiement ce que je
peux vous dire est que nous avons dit de
façon constante le gouvernement du mali
afin communiqué absolument très clair
sur la question
la coopération avec la russie et une
coopération historique notre coopération
avec la russie est une coopération
d'état à état le mari ne s'adresse
qu'aux gouvernements russes qui
répondent à nos sollicitations avec une
grande célérité une grande efficacité
les sept derniers mois les équipements
et les fournitures qui a été acquis via
cette coopération n'ont jamais été ce
type d'investissement n'ont jamais été
fait au cours des quinze ou vingt
dernières années le problème du mali
n'est pas wagner le problème du mari
c'est un problème d'apporter la sécu et
théo malienne et aux maliens c'est notre
responsabilité et nous ferons tout ce
qui est nécessaire conformément à la loi
et conformément aux traités
internationaux pour pouvoir répondre à
cela que nous souhaitons que les autres
qui sont en train maintenant de faire
toute cette campagne autour de wagner
qui prennent un peu de recul qui
viennent voir avec le mali quels
problèmes sécuritaires vous avez et
qu'elle peut être notre contribution à
pouvoir résoudre je pense que c'est ce
dialogue que nous attendons de nos
partenaires
depuis le 9 janvier monsieur le ministre
votre pays est lourdement sanctionnée
par vos voisins de la cedeao mais dans
un communiqué hier la cedeao dit
attendre de vous un calendrier
raisonnable et réaliste pour la tenue
des élections
elle ajoute que les sanctions seront
levés progressivement sur la base de ce
chronogramme et de sa mise en oeuvre est
ce pour vous une petite ouverture cette
politique des sanctions il faut qu'on
sorte le seul à le mali ce dont nous
avons besoin c'est l'accompagnement
celle écoute c'est le dialogue c'est la
compréhension aujourd'hui si les
sanctions contre le mali qui sont des
actions au delà de la normale était
efficace il ne se serait pas passé
monsieur le ministre on comprend que
healy a en effet un dialogue sur ce
fameux chronogramme vous aviez proposé
initialement cinq ans puis quatre ans le
président algérien vous avez parlé de
l'algérie abdel majid teboul lui propose
une transition qui dure 16 mois au
maximum est ce que pour vous ça c'est
une option viable c'est un compromis
possible de façon très concrète nous
restons ouverts pour pouvoir convenir de
la période la plus appropriée et qui
prenne en compte l'intérêt supérieur du
mali mais seize mois c'est possible
qu'ils prennent en compte les exigences
elles
jeudi que toutes les options nous sommes
ouverts à examiner tout ça je ne peux
pas à votre micro répondre à cette
question c'est l'objet de consultations
qui sont en cours ne nous focalisons pas
sur le lean durée de seize mois deux ans
ou trois ans assez stable nous voulons
qu'on regarde ensemble qu'est ce qui est
prévu qui est important pour le mali qui
important pour le peuple malien qui est
sortie qui a montré que je ne peux pas
faire juste des élections et de tourner
le dos si on est d'accord sur ça nous
sommes gouvernent si le temps que le
mali propose est trop long si des
partenaires dans la discussion arrive à
nous convaincre d'une durée moindre il
faut qu'on regarde quel pas les
partenaires doit faire pour aider le
mali à pouvoir faire les choses dans une
durée relativement plus courte que ce
qui est vous dites monsieur le ministre
que le coup d'état au burkina faso
prouve
l'inefficacité des mesures cedeao contre
votre pays à ce à dire que quand vous
avez appris ce coup d'état lundi dernier
ben vous avez applaudi vous vous êtes
sentie moins seule
nous n'avons pas applaudi vous savez
toute rupture de l'ordre constitutionnel
n'est pas normal et c'est des situations
qui rappelle aussi qu'il d'abord créé de
l'inquiétude et de l'incertitude par
rapport à la vie mais bcp
mais en même temps il faut comprendre
que les coups d'état eux mêmes bien
souvent des problèmes de gouvernance qui
n'ont pas été traités ou qui n'ont pas
été bien traité dans le cas particulier
du burkina comme dans celui du mali qui
est aussi emblématique de la situation
de l'ensemble du sahel lettre de
traitement des questions sécuritaires et
les réponses qui ont été apportées sont
aujourd'hui des questions qui
préoccupent nos populations nos
populations sont exaspérés par cette
insécurité qui ne fait que grandir ils
demandent des résultats au pouvoir
politique demande des résultats aux
militaires je ne suis je ne suis pas
fondées de donner une appréciation sur
ce qui se passe au burkina je fais
confiance au génie du peuple burkinabè
pour pouvoir apporter des réponses nous
nous sommes voisins nous démarrons
solidaire du combat du peuple burkinabè
mais notre préoccupation c'est de
répondre aux besoins des maliens nous
restons ouverts à cheminer avec
l'ensemble des peuples de la région et
de l'ensemble des peuples africains qui
partagent notre vision alors est-ce que
vous avez pris attache avec les
militaires désormais au pouvoir
à ouagadougou est ce que par exemple les
colonels goïta et damiba se sont parlés
a personnellement je n'ai pas
d'information à ce niveau mais le mali
parle à tout le monde nous parlons à
tous nos frères quelles que soient les
conditions dans lesquelles ils se
trouvent parce que nous partageons les
mêmes frontières nous avons des destins
communs et nous pensons que seulement
c'est dans le dialogue et la
concertation que nous pouvons trouver
des solutions loin de nous toute l'idée
de donner des leçons à qui que ce soit
et d'un mot monsieur le ministre il nous
reste quelques secondes pensez vous qu
après ce troisième coup d'état dans un
pays de la cedeao est bien celle ci
cette cedeao va devoir changer d'avis va
devoir changer d'attitude à votre égard
nous l'espérons nous l'espérons parce
que c'est ce que nous essayons
d'expliquer nos organisations la cedeao
l'union africaine ou do i doivent
changer de logiciel de notre point de
vue qu'on doit s'en sortir et un peu de
ces manuels de ce playbook qui disent un
peu calé un coup d'état bonsoir on
condamne enfin sommet extraordinaire en
25 6 7 mois les situations sont
différentes les problèmes sont
différents ils comprendre le temps de
regarder qu'on regarde seulement qui a
pas que le coude et agir il ya des
changements anticonstitutionnels qui se
passe dans nos pays où nos organisations
et restent les bras croisés il ne
faudrait elles ne font rien pour faire
face à cela et aujourd'hui c'était même
traitement de
géométrie variable qui pose problème
dont nous devons évaluer et l'ensemble
de nos dispositifs de réponse à ces
changements anticonstitutionnels coup
d'état militaire ou coup d'état civil
pour pouvoir apporter de solutions
soyons à l'écouté des populations
dans le cas du mali nous avons vu les
populations qui sont sorties massivement
pour végéter cette politique de la
cedeao nous avons vu aussi dans
l'ensemble des capitales beaucoup de
pays africains la jeunesse est sorti
pour dire ce qu'elle veut prenons le
temps nécessaire d'écouter nos jeunes
prenons le temps d'écouter les
préoccupations de nos populations et de
trouver entre africains les moyens
nécessaires et nous dénonçons encore une
fois aujourd'hui l'instrumentalisation
de nos organisations régionales à
d'autres desseins inavoués qu'on laisse
les africains et même trouvé les moins
des solutions africaines à nos problèmes
que nos partenaires sont toujours les
bienvenus mais je crois que la
contribution n'est pas au delà parce
qu'ils ne sont pas membres de son
organisation merci monsieur le ministre
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et merci
à vous de nous avoir suivi sur nos deux
médias france 24 et radio france
internationale
[Musique]